[Music]
thank you
Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host and analyst for football night
in America he's going to be in the booth
with Mike Tarico this weekend Big Ten
football it's Michigan against East
Carolina that will be at noon Eastern
and he of course has the Chris Sims
unbuttoned podcast as well
uh how big of a story is Jim Harbaugh
not coaching the first three games going
to be on your broadcast this weekend
well I mean we're certainly going to hit
on it you know I mean it he is Jim
Harbaugh he's you know one of the the
best coaches in college football he's
kind of a polarizing personality so and
we're at Michigan and yeah we're gonna
hit on that I'm sure a good amount but
you know I think big picture of things
first three games of the year Michigan's
really talented you know they got a lot
of older veteran type of players for a
college football team I don't think it's
going to affect them very much and we
know he's gonna be all over that program
even if he's not you know on the field
with them on a every minute day-to-day
basis okay but how did it go from
Harbaugh was in Jeopardy of losing his
job getting a pay cut and now he's one
of the great coaches in college football
yeah well you know I think results
what's happened the last few years the
mark market place right there's you know
teams that have been interested in them
there was no doubt the Denver Broncos
wanted to hire Jim Harbaugh last year so
I think between that and where they've
been as a program they won Harbaugh
before they wanted Sean Payton in Denver
definitely yes a hundred percent so he
was the first choice he was Davis the
First Choice yes and and you know I
think it kind of he hemmed and hauled a
little bit there about you know oh I
might take the job and then he didn't
and then he kind of went oh I might take
it and then he didn't and that's my
understanding right would you take Sean
Payton or Jim Harbaugh if you're done so
you're just trying to start a fight with
me and Jim Harbaugh right off the bat
here huh uh no I mean I
um well I I would I'm a Big Sean Payton
fan that's not listen I'm I'm from the
Bill Parcells Phil Sims Bill Belichick
School of coaching so I certainly
respect Jim Harbaugh's approach and what
he does Sean Payton's also in that
school of coaching though you know he
worked under parcels and he's got a
blend of offensive genius with
physicality to go along with it you know
those Saints teams before he left hey
they were big and physical on both sides
of the ball and I don't think he gets
credit for that you know part of his
coaching so yeah I guess I'd take Sean
Payton yeah Shirley a quarterback era
offensive mind like that yeah I'm gonna
take him
can Russell Wilson play his way out of
the Hall of Fame
yes
is he is he
is he in the Hall of Fame no no is he
well oh yeah yeah last year if he has a
bad year this year like it felt like he
was a Hall of Famer with Seattle
right right I I'm with you I mean it's
certainly the trajectory where he was
going was was Hall of Fame if it
continues to be what it was last year
and we look at Denver and go you know
whoa they're having to still manipulate
the offense and kind of you know manage
him to a degree and then things he can
and can't do yeah it's going to take
some luster off and especially with Sean
Payton you know that puts more of a
bullseye on it I mean again we saw what
he did with Drew Brees even what he did
with Drew Brees towards the end of his
career when he wasn't you know the Drew
Brees we Remembered in his prime so we
expect results he's going to have
answers he's got a better offensive line
I'd be shocked if Russell Wilson doesn't
look more like the Hall of Fame type guy
uh over the guy we saw last year what
are the Patriots doing
it's a great I know Lori and I talked
about that today it was it was a shocker
it was a shocker in the sense of you
know what's the plan there's no veteran
out there that you look at that go oh
well they'll sign him I mean I know Colt
McCoy's out there but the thing I always
bring up with New England that offense
is a different language than most
offenses in football so it's not like
you can just go hey we're gonna sign a
guy off the street and he'll get up to
speed here in two or three weeks it's
gonna take some time you know so that's
where I don't understand it I think
ultimately Bailey's Abby will be back
practice squad back up I think they're
probably trying to finagle some roster
spots here hope some other teams you
know maybe fill some roster spots so now
they don't need one of their guys and
they can stash him on practice squad I
think he got a little of that going on
but this too Dan you can't forget about
this all right New England for one has
always been you know Phil Sims Tom Brady
Drew Bledsoe Vinnie tester they like
those type of quarterbacks right I never
thought bayley zappy was really their
cup of tea and then the other thing on
top of that is he didn't play well this
preseason you know he didn't get much
talk about it but the last two games
were not impressive the first game
wasn't that impressive he didn't look
even good physically nor did he make
necessarily great decisions and I think
that led us to where we are right now
too he's Chris Sims pro football talk
live co-host an analyst on football
night America
which coach is more likely to have a hot
seat
Bill Belichick or Nick Saban oh
I think I mean it's crazy either way
right but Belichick
you know let's say they win six games
this year yeah yeah it's hot seat time
yeah at what point does Robert Kraft go
bill
maybe time to you know have some nice
parting gifts here yeah well in my heart
of hearts right and you know I know I
know people connected to the situation
and nobody knows definitively but I
would say it's this year or next year or
the last year for Bill Belichick okay
not only people that know him and
connected to him you know just other
things I've heard as well I think we're
going that direction yes you go six and
eleven he might be showing the door a
little quicker than maybe he would like
right uh and and you know again they're
a franchise that's very proud and I am a
little shocked at how the New England
fan base has been as critical as
Belichick has you know ever since Brady
left but that's just the way the current
statuses of the professional sports and
Saban College a little different and
there's still a prime awesome football
team in college football why is Trey
Lance a bust but the person who drafted
him not considered a bust in their job
they made the mistake yeah no you're
right I mean listen well Shanahan the
evaluator or or Shanahan the coach saved
in the evaluator right we've seen that
before we could say that about the guy
we just talked about Belichick he always
made some you know questionable lose
second third round first round picks
where we were like but it didn't matter
because he coached his way out of it
we're going no Darren there they are in
the AFC Championship Game you know I
don't ever fault Shanahan John Lynch
they they they took their cut right they
took their swing they wanted an upgraded
quarterback they tried to get a guy that
they believed they can make into a
superstar a Josh Allen and mahomes-ish
you know I never saw that right so
they've gotten Flack out there it
certainly has hurt their football team
but you know for that move I could tell
you 10 other moves they made and go damn
that was a good one that was an
impressive draft pick right there oh
look at this mid-round guy that's
awesome and all that so where as we both
know that's it's one of the better
orchestrated teams in all of football
and I know because it's the Cowboys
that's going to Garner more headlines
more coverage with Trey Lance going
there but I I'm just trying to
understand this he got no playing time
with San Francisco he was injured lost
out to Sam darnold as the backup
quarterback how's this going to be
better he's not better than Cooper rush
in Dallas no no so he's going to put
pressure on Dak Prescott
these are all the things that I raised
these questions too I'm with you in that
logic one Hey listen I was shocked the
49ers even got a fourth round pick and
got the Cowboys to pay the 5.9 million
or 5.4 million whatever it was I mean
that was shocking to me I mean if my
buddy Kyle Shanahan had called me I'd be
like you're not getting anything for him
dude you better keep him or or you're
just gonna have to release them I I
would not have thought that now you know
whether there's some other I know there
were some teams that were thinking about
it did it become a bidding war I don't
know you know I do think Shanahan was
very open to keeping him so that
probably dropped drove up the price a
little bit but yeah the logic of Dallas
you hit it Dan one hey Cooper Rush is a
pretty good backup is the high-end
potential at Trail lands greater than
Cooper Rush sure but the thing I keep
going back to is he hasn't played
football in three years I mean we're
going on four years here I don't know
unders and then he's gonna learn a new
offense so I don't think he's beating
out Cooper rush anytime soon and then so
and then we're gonna go what into the
off season and go oh if he has a good
off season this is going to put pressure
on Dak Prescott to renegotiate his
contract I it seems far-fetched to me it
seems like there's you know hoping to
strike gold here and put pressure on the
Dak Prescott situation but I don't know
in reality if that's gonna actually
happen I asked this earlier more likely
to win their division the Jets or the
Packers oh
well okay AFC East
you know the Jets and the Dolphins are
the two most talented teams in that
division uh I have no qualms about
saying that
if you gave me more likely I'm gonna go
with the Green Bay Packers I think the
Green Bay Packers have the best roster
in the NFC North I know Jordan loves a
question mark he got better in every
game I saw enough to go I had to do this
on my podcast yesterday I picked Green
Bay to win the north Dan I did so that's
out there I picked Miami to win the East
barely over the Jets and I put the bills
third and the Patriots fourth right so
uh the AFC is crazy this year it's going
to be fun but I'm not giving up on the
Packers and what they've built there
ever see somebody get cut
yeah yeah I mean like cut like
physically cut or no I mean I've been
cut cut from the roster but but yeah but
watching somebody like how does it work
where they call somebody in oh and you
could be waiting because you might get
called in as well but what's that
feeling like are you in the locker room
and then they go hey Tommy come here
yeah yeah it's usually like that there's
a guy that goes around that's the Grim
Reaper right he's the Grim Reaper the
turn that day the turkey right something
like that he's holding a clipboard and
he's you know hey can you come up to
coach's office and usually it is a day
where everybody's there and usually
unless you're you know one of the 10
best players on the team everybody's
looking out of the corner of their eye
everybody and yeah when you see him walk
in and you know you're not one of those
top guys of the team you always are like
oh here he comes where which direction
he's going oh he didn't come for me so
you're happy about that and then you go
oh man there goes there goes Tommy
Tommy's gonna get cut damn that's man I
can't believe they're gonna cut Tommy
it's it's an odd day in the NFL it
really is and you know having having the
Grim Reaper come towards me I wasn't
sure I was literally one of those guys
where I was like I don't know I'm making
a good amount of money this year but
they don't have a real viable backup you
know I still wasn't the same after my
injury and I remember when the guy
started coming my way I kind of slumped
my shoulders and I was like man really
and he looked at me and it's like I'm
sorry Chris and it's just you know it's
a horrible feeling it really is
especially for people who have been at
the top of sports for a long time and
all of a sudden you're told you're not
good enough on on this occasion did you
cry
I'm a crier I didn't cry you know I
cried there I did I cried I did and now
that I'm remembering it you're bringing
me back there I cried as I was kind of
saying bye to Josh McDaniels Brian
Sanders the GM you know you you get sad
about the relationships where's my life
gonna go but me crying's no big thing
Dan I'm a crier anyways like like my
family makes fun of me I'm a crier when
the Super Bowl's about to start I'm a
crier an Armageddon when the guy tells
you know uh Ben Affleck's you know soon
to be wife permission to shake the hand
of the bravest you know or the daughter
of the bravest man I'm I'm the worst
that way so don't don't look at me like
that
do they escort you out of the building
when you get cut
they they don't escort you but they keep
their eye on you right so when I was
with the Denver Broncos and got cut I
wanted to keep my Josh McDaniels new win
you know New England offensive stuff I
was thinking I might be a coach either
way even if I wasn't a coach I'd like to
have it you know some of the play sheets
The Playbook I was gonna steal all that
I was gonna go I'm taking this and screw
you I'm out of here but they watched me
out of their corner of their eye and
they saw me put that damn thing in my
bag and they said no no we got to take
that and they took it and I was like
really come on Josh knows I'm not you
know uh but but yeah they they watch you
and then you know don't escort you out
of the building but shake your hand and
hey say see you later but you're allowed
to keep your jersey
glad to keep your jersey kept my helmet
right you you get some of that stuff for
sure yeah yeah you do but you know
that's it's things you don't really care
about at the time but it's cool you know
a few years down the road sorry to bring
up the emotional baggage that you carry
about it's okay I got over it PTSD I
smoked that away a long time ago don't
worry you literally smoke that away yes
I did
but your dad is one of the toughest guys
who ever played the position juxtapose
that with you that you're crying as
you're leaving like well is your dad a
crier no he's not but you know what
what's crying got to do with toughness
you know that's what I say I've seen
some I've seen some of the toughest
people I've ever met in life where I'd
go I wouldn't fight that guy if you gave
me a million dollars in cash and I'd
seen him cry a few times my dad's you
know old school Kentucky I mean I don't
think he said I love you until I was 17
years old and I just broke him down
finally right so that's just not in him
and uh yeah it's it's been very limited
times I've seen you know my dad shed a
tear it's usually with death or
something like that and this is feels
like a therapy session
it is it's always a therapy session with
you Dan you're like the Mastermind of
questions and setting people up you are
you're the Mastermind uh have fun with
tariko there and uh play nice in Ann
Arbor
I will I will tell all those jerks I
said hi uh I assume he's talking about
you guys wow Chris says hey you jerks
hey Chris he says fine thank you Chris
hey guys that's uh Chris Sims pro
football talk live co-host